daniela guillerme didier hotte bonjour
merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur rtl
france didier hotte je me tourne vers
vous on le disait jean castex en
déplacement aujourd'hui en bourgogne
alors que la loi grand âge elle est
enterrée qu'est ce que vous attendez
aujourd'hui du premier ministre
écoutez on aurait souhaité effectivement
déjà avoir des éclaircissements sur
cette future loi grand âge même si
madame bourguignons qui est en charge
les dossiers ne nous a pas laissé
beaucoup d'espoir quant à l'arrivée de
cette loi avant la fin de ce mandat mais
on a le sentiment qu'en définitive c'est
reporté à meilleure fortune des finances
publiques comme disait un ministre
autrefois on va quand même rappeler que
la situation des aidants n'a pas
beaucoup évolué depuis la loi promener
par madame delaunay et qu' il faudrait
rappeler également que pour un aidant en
moyenne en moyenne jeudi à bien ce à peu
près de 2000 euros par an pour s'occuper
des personnes dont elles ont la charge
or pour l'instant on ne voit pas
vraiment arrivé quelque chose qui
améliore la situation je rappelle que
les prestations de compensation ne sont
pas très élevés et que or ce qui
concerne le droit au répit bien c'est un
montant de 2 à peu près 500 euros par an
qui est prévu et de ce point de vue là
c'est loin de faire de faire la faire
pour la plupart des aidants donc
effectivement je dirais que le
ruissellement en ce qui les concerne il
se fait plutôt un an d'ailleurs pour
elle rappelle que les retraités en plus
représente un quart de la population
française daniel guillerme les aidants
pendant le confinement ont été très
sollicités aujourd'hui un appel à la
mobilisation a été lancé leurs
conditions de travail sont difficiles
toujours
il faut s'entendre sur le terme des
dents vous avez d'un côté en fait les
professionnels du médico social et des
soignants et puis vous avez l'entourage
en fait de familiale ou proches ont des
proches du patient qu'on appelle les
hesdin maintenant il est clair que dans
une politique
incantatoire en tout cas de da proches
domiciliaire et de maintien à domicile
des personnes âgées en perte d'autonomie
on a aujourd'hui un fossé entre les
besoins et les moyens alloués et moi je
le dis depuis longtemps et on a eu
l'occasion de le dire lors d'une
audition par par l'igas l'inspection
générale des affaires sociales que sent
lésé dans le virage domicile air est
condamné il est d'autant plus important
après ce qu'on a vu pendant le
confinement notamment dans les ehpad
avec toutes ces toutes ces morts de
personnes âgées
c'est vrai que la pandémie a mis en
lumière effectivement des des
distorsions au niveau des hauts niveaux
des ehpad avant je pense que le modèle
aujourd'hui est sur la sellette
le modèle entre guillemets
concentrationnaire c'est un terme
peut-être un peu un peu fort mais en
tout état de cause le projet de loi
génération solidaire avait pour objectif
d'ouvrir les ehpad à la ville et on
avait des mesures en fait qui seront
peut-être reporter pour certaines
d'entre elles dans le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale 2022
on avait des mesures qui avait pour
objectif de sortir de ce modèle pour
mettre en place un modèle d'après crise
qui ne présenterait pas en fait les
distorsions constaté lors de la pandémie
didier hotte aujourd'hui la priorité
c'est de favoriser la dda domicile pour
pour les personnes âgées
écoutez il est évident que la plupart
des personnes âgées souhaitent rester à
domicile
77 % d'aidés et des vivres à domicile
ceci étant tout en comprenant
parfaitement cette question je ne pense
pas qu'il faille pour autant
arrêter la création de l'ehpad où est
renvoyée cela au secteur privé je pense
que à partir d'un certain âge
la situation des personnes
m avec toutes les aides nécessaires ben
justifie que elles fassent leur entrée
dans un ehpad alors maintenant bon c'est
pas du tout je dirais à modèle que je
défends tant que tel mais je considère
que c'est quand même nécessaire de
prévoir des structures et que les
structures publiques ont quand même
l'avantagé par de coûter moins cher mais
on voudrait pas que le le virage
domiciliaire soit en quelque sorte un
moyen détourné de faire des économies
pour l'état et pour la future 5e caisse
de l'autonomie et que en quelque sorte
le village domiciliaire soit le pendant
du du virage pardon ambulatoire à
l'hôpital c'est à dire bon ben on essaye
de faire en sorte que les séjours ou
dure le moins longtemps possible comme
ça ça permet d'économiser délit ce n'est
pas le but pour nous c'est tout
simplement un choix de vie si le choix
de vie ce fait nos bonnes conditions y'a
pas de problème mais pour l'instant le
choix de vie rester à domicile c'est
vrai c'était quand même quelque chose
qui est quand même très onéreux et
surtout très taxant au sens général pour
les personnes qui aident leurs à leurs
proches de leur famille etc je suis plus
effectivement sur les aidants familiaux
que les en professionnel mais je le
considère qu effectivement il ya aussi
un effort à faire en matière de création
de postes de professionnels au service
des personnes âgées et que de ce point
de vue là les promesses qui ont été
faites et bien pour l'instant on ne voit
toujours pas la réalisation en daniel
guillerme est ce que les les aidons ont
été les grands oubliés de du quoi qu'il
en coûte emmanuel macron la fédération
nationale des infirmiers a écrit une
lettre ouverte à emmanuel macron
puisqu'il ya eu aussi ce rabotage de la
rémunération des des visites au domicile
des personnes âgées de quoi s'agit-il
exactement
nous avions négocié un dispositif qui
permettait effectivement de forfaitisés
des prises en charge infirmière au
domicile des patients on a constaté en
fait un dépassement de l' enveloppe
assez important
les en partie en tout cas à la pandémie
et je vous rappelle qu'en mars 2020 les
infirmières libérales était quasiment
les seuls professionnels de santé à se
déplacer au domicile de patients on
s'était fixé un double objectif
maintenir autant que faire se peut ces
patients fragiles à domicile pour éviter
l'implosion des files actives au niveau
des services d'urgence et de l'hôpital
donc on a tenu les lignes au mois de
mars
avec sont les implications budgétaires
que ça peut avoir et aujourd'hui on nous
dit vous avez dépassé votre enveloppe
négocier il va falloir rendre l'argent
donc c'est là où civique il ya une
distorsion aujourd'hui entre les besoins
et les moyens alloués donc on ne peut
pas être dans une allocution paradoxale
qui consiste à dire on va mettre en
place comme socle de la stratégie
nationale de santé le virage ambulatoire
avec aujourd'hui ce postulat de la
proche domiciliaire et du matière à
domicile sans y mettre les moyens corpiq
pardon mais quand vous voyez manuel
macron kiki qui ouvre le carnet de
chèques qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
quelle est votre réaction
notre réaction c'est qu'il faut en fait
dans le système de santé
de l'aide à domicile
jusqu'aux médecins spécialistes rétablir
en fait une forme d'équité
à un système de santé c'est un ensemble
de rouages on a besoin des aides à
domicile on a besoin des professionnels
de santé on a besoin des médecins mais
il faut pas qu'il y avait effectivement
une inéquité parce que si dans un
système vous avez un rouage qui est
grippé c'est aussi stabilité didier
hotte le mot de la fin de manière
générale est ce que vous estimez que les
personnes âgées sl sont
les grandes oubliées finalement de la
politique publique
bah écoutez elles ont déjà été un peu
les sacrifiés au début de la pandémie
puisque je rappelle que une instruction
ministérielle
visait à interdire leur accès aux
urgences au moment de la première vague
ce qui fait que ma la moitié à peu près
des décès de personnes âgées auront lieu
dans les ehpad ce qui était quand même
assez révélateur d'une part du fait que
les services d'urgence était certain
danger mais aussi du fait que les lits
de réanimation manqué dans ce pays je
rappelle qu'ils sont pour un même ratio
d'habitants bien inférieurs à ceux de
l'allemagne ou de la belgique et que de
ce point de vue en gironde et dans une
suite logique il ya le côté priorité au
point de vue sanitaire ça ne peut pas
être les personnes âgées donc on les
laisse de côté et puis il ya aussi le
côté je dirais financiers
le but hp dirait des politiques le
public depuis plusieurs années c'est
tout simplement de réduire le montant
des retraites par rapport au produit
intérieur brut que d'en dire réduire en
fait les moyens financiers étaient
retraités or au moment où qu'ils vont
devoir affronter des dépenses justement
pour le maintien de vie s'il on peut pas
dire que le signal envoyé par le dernier
budget soit extrêmement positif c'est
une litote pour dire qu'il est carrément
négatif merci beaucoup d'idées ôté et
merci à vous daniel guillerme d'avoir
été en direct ce matin sur rtl france